foreign
and yesterday I took the train to Berlin
because junto is hosting an evening
event here this evening for investors
for customers and other partners very
much looking forward to that so welcome
to another coffee break here on my
channel from learning my name is
Heinrich and on my Channel I want to
help you to become successful in the
first years of your career today in this
video I will first talk about what it's
like to be a business Angel how it all
works what the learnings are that I took
from my first investment and I will also
talk about yunto wildshos that specific
company and how you can find companies
to invest in this way there are many
reasons why one might want to become a
business Angel one of them is for sure
the potential Financial rewards in one
of my last videos I talked about how
important that might be for you I will
link the video somewhere above here the
alternative to investing in startups
might be to start your own startup to
found your own business and of course if
you are able to build a unicorn and then
do a successful exit you might take home
a hundred million euro or even more
right so that's surely the case but at
the other hand side that's of course
also very risky I don't want to bore you
with all these statistics on how many
companies fail but you could argue that
being a business Angel provides you
still with the upside of having a
life-changing financial event of maybe
done exiting with a couple of million
euro which according to this last video
will be life-changing for you for sure
without all the risk of doing it just
with one company right because you can
hedge your bets across a basket I will
talk more about that in a moment now
before we jump into the details I do
want to make the disclaimer that first
this is not supposed to be Financial
advice second I'm surely not
recommending to all of you to normal
business Angel Investments and third I'm
not talking here from the position of an
expert but it has started doing this
myself over the last two years I talked
to many experienced business agents and
I just want to pass on some first
learnings that I have acquired over this
journey with you here in this video so
what does it mean to be a business angel
in its easiest form it means that you
find startups find young companies you
provide them with money and they in
return provide you with stocks of the
company so with Equity if you look at
the life cycle of a startup you usually
want to invest in the very early stages
of that company people often call these
status the pre-seat stage to the seed
stage this is a terminology that is
widely accepted in the community now
what exactly qualifies a startup to be
in one of these stages depends on the
industry on the type of the business and
so on there is a widely respected napkin
from the big we see from 0.9 and they
Define the pre-seed stage in the way
that you can see it here with these
typical evaluations and this then can be
contrasted by the seed stage so what you
can clearly see here is that in the
pre-seed stage the company often doesn't
even have a product it's more or less
just a team so you do need to make your
investment decision just on the merits
of this team contrasted to the seed
stage often the first prototype of a
product already exists maybe already the
first one two three customers have been
acquired and so this does give you a
couple of additional data points so then
base your investment decisions on so
what this of course means is because
you're investing so early that the risk
is very high the chance of failure is
very high very significant and I want to
make this really clear on the other hand
side of course the potential upside if
then the business does indeed develop
well is very high as well I will talk
more about the economics of business
Angel Investing in a moment now the
first question that you should answer is
why should a company even take money
from you and maybe this question
surprises you shouldn't companies be
happy if you are willing to invest in
them and when the answer is yes or no
surely you will find lots of companies
that would be happy to take your money
but at the other hand side the most
promising most exciting Style startups
often have lots of people who want to
invest in them lots of people who want
to give them money so you need to ask
yourself what is actually the value add
that you can deliver potentially also
Beyond just investing the money that
then gives a reason for this company to
choose you as a business angel investor
so what value can you add as a business
agent and that of course Depends for a
single person for myself I'd like to
think that that's first my reach with my
for learning platform so this can help
in first delivering relevant sales leads
but also get interest from potential
employees and recruiting is often a very
big pain point for fast growing
companies second with my work here at
from learning I did require quite some
knowledge on social media marketing and
this is a topic that is increasingly
important for B2B business companies as
well this is a key sales and recruiting
channel for these firms and third last
but not least it is my network that I
acquired from working in Consulting at
McKinsey from working in industry in
startup and of course knowing today now
many other influencers in the field who
might be very relevant to get in touch
with with the companies as well and
these might be similar points you can
deliver as well your expertise your
knowledge your contacts your network all
of these things are potentially relevant
to companies you'd want to invest in and
of course there are also some companies
who are just happy to take the money
from you to get the investment and many
investors will tell you that often the
correlation between how hyped the
startup was in the beginning and how
successful it turned out to be in the
end is often not even that pronounced so
don't let yourself get fooled by the
hype that maybe surrounds the one or
other company in the beginning so the
big question is how do you find the best
startups to invest in and ideally you
are able to not only look at a handful
of companies but look at lots of
companies and then be able to really
hand pick the ones that are most in line
with your target investment profile over
time one of the most important sources
of potential is startups investment is
your network if you have the reputation
that you are an easy person to work with
that you're delivering real value to the
startups this news will spread in the
startup ecosystem and you will be
proactively approached not only by
potential startup Founders but maybe
also by VCS Venture Capital firms and
other players of the ecosystem who might
want to get you inside the do you get
you on board as a business Angel so your
reputation is key this will be
determining your success to help you
select the company so that you really do
want to invest in it is helpful to ask
yourself what does Target profile should
be so at what stage do you want to
invest in is it rather precede so very
very early on where the risk of course
is often a little bit higher because
they are just barely starting out but at
the other hand side often also get a bit
more for your money or do you want to
get in at maybe a seed stage or maybe
the risk is a little bit smaller because
a bit more advanced but then of course
also you are Angel tickets will get you
less shares right so ask this yourself
also other certain topics certain
industries certain types of startups
you're especially passionate about maybe
because also you are able to add Special
Value to these types of companies these
things you should have them very clear
because this will help you to select the
companies that you want to invest in one
of the most important things to look out
for when evaluating young companies is
the team the founding team because often
there's not much more out there to
evaluate than the team itself so let me
give you a couple of things to look out
for that also other investors we look
out for so these things are not right
these companies might also struggle to
get financing from Big Renault VCS and
so on but also keep in mind that these
considerations are always rules of thumb
so you will always find exceptions to
this rule as well and the first is that
people don't really like single Founders
so single individual people who found a
company and the reason is that these
people might be overwhelmed in the end
right too much pressure too much
responsibility for just one person so a
dealer founder teams off now two to
three people for funding the company
this is what you want to go for second
is the background of the founding team
ideally you find people who have a
proven track record of success we've
shown in the past that they can overcome
adversity that they are resourceful that
they can handle challenges difficult
situations and so on and this can be due
to a very ambitious and successful CV up
to that point that can be due to
successfully having founded a company in
the past often people do also like
former mbb consultants for instance or
former Bankers because these people have
shown that they are able to work under
pressure and get things done but of
course important as well is the idea
that you're being pitched with because
the truth is if you want to earn serious
money with business Angel Investments
what you need to look out for are
companies that have the potential to
turn into unicorns so companies with
evaluation of over 1 billion Euro or
dollar doesn't matter in the current
parity of these currencies so ask
yourself what problem do they want to
solve is is it significant enough that
if done correctly this has the potential
to maybe at some point turn to the new
Google turn it into the new meter turn
into the new epic right this should
always be at the core of your
consideration if you're not able to at
least have the chance for a company to
grow to such an extent likely you will
just burn money with your investment of
course if this is the main goal of what
you're doing
[Music]
now let's imagine you found a startup
you talk to each other and there's a
mutual interest in doing this investment
The Next Step might be a due diligence
right don't you have to now do a legal
review of the status of the company of
everything that's going on well in here
I think many people are wasting lots of
time money resources what I learned from
talking to more experienced business
angels is that many of them actually
don't conduct any due diligence in terms
of illegal due diligence at all and the
reason being that very early on when the
startup is just getting started often
you don't have much to check anywhere
right I mean what exactly do you want to
look at and second if you hire a law for
really do a full investigation for that
you will just often spend a multiple of
your actual Angel ticket just on legal
visa and so on so it doesn't really seem
to be worth it because what's the worst
that can happen to you in at least most
cases it's losing the initial investment
if your invest in slightly later stages
may be a seed stage it might also be
worth looking for other investors right
to join the deal so who is the lead
investor this is a big renowned VC
Venture Capital firm then charges are
very high usually you can trust that
actually this VC did carry out a
professional due diligence of such an
investor did decide to invest chances
are high that actually there's nothing
that this company is hiding that they're
looking good at least from a legal
perspective in addition to that the big
VCS have also reputation to lose for
themselves so often they will want to
make sure the business agents are
investing and actually Fair conditions
that no one is getting screwed over
because of this is the reputation that
these companies have then in the future
no other business angels will want to
join their deals so this can be an
additional level of security that you
might have years later one tip or more
experienced investor shared with me when
evaluating startups especially in the
pre-seed stage is to spend time with
them over the period of a couple of
weeks and then ask yourself what
progress did the team show in these
weeks if the team said that they will do
something did they actually do this how
reliable are they and then based on all
of this you can come to the conclusion
whether you do want to make the
investment or not now let's talk about
the economics of business Angel
Investing and I trust this is a question
that many of you have how much money do
I need to actually start as a business
agent and maybe it surprises you that
typical business Angel tickets are
somewhere in the range of starting at 5
000 Euro up to maybe 50 000 Euros and
there are many business agents doing
typical tickets of 10 to 20 000 Euros so
this is something that can get you
started at the same time I would advise
you against just doing one or two
business Angel Investments especially if
you're mainly doing it for the potential
Financial rewards the reason being that
the risk is of course very high if you
put all your eggs in one or two baskets
what I would recommend you to do is to
make a plan so let say you have 120 000
Euro available that you want to put into
startups as a business agent a typical
plan could be that now you decide to
split this into 10 tickets of 10 000
Euro each and you keep the additionally
20 000 for legal fees and other
miscellaneous items that you might be
faced with now if you dig into the legal
topics of course there are all types of
Clauses provisions and so on and so
forth that might be relevant to you and
I will not even attempt to explain all
of them to you two thoughts on this
first much more important than really
negotiating and understanding all of
this is actually picking the right
companies this is what in the end we'll
drive the return for you and not if
you're able to negotiate a double
liquidation preference or not or
anything of the likes and so second my
recommendation would be to pair up with
a lawyer who could do just a very basic
review of the term sheets to check that
there's nothing in there which is super
unusual and as a bonus tip another more
experienced business angel following
very basic question with me to make sure
that you're not unfairly treated and
this is to ask whether you will receive
the same share class so the same type of
shares as all the other investors in the
round because if the answer is yes then
you can be quite sure that at least this
is not something to screw you over then
at least you can potentially trust that
other more experienced investors in the
round will have negotiated all these
Basics things in the good and correct
way so if you do all that if you did
find 10 companies to invest in in this
way what you will be hoping for is that
only one of them actually makes it only
one of them turns maybe into a unicorn
because if this is the case very likely
if you did everything correctly you will
not only recover the investment of all
your other startups of all the other
tickets that you placed but in addition
to that due to the Returns on this one
thing that then actually made it and was
successful you will very likely go home
with potentially several millions in the
bank but of because be aware that the
time Horizon for this is rather a
long-term Horizon it can easily take
five to ten years to really realize any
of the gains that you can accrue by
investing in these startups sometimes
even longer so surely do not invest any
money that you really couldn't live with
if you lose that money do not invest
money that really you need in the next
years surely investing as a business
Angel is a rather Advanced way of
investing and not necessarily something
for beginners
[Music]
thank you
so we arrived here at the evening event
of yunto the startup company I invested
in end of last year it's going to be an
exciting evening about personal branding
strategies with great speakers such as
Tiana Sullivan and Celine Villas very
much looking forward and join me now
[Music]
foreign
ER of June Tomatoes first of all thanks
for the invitation that I'm able to join
this event it has been an awesome
evening for the uninitiated out there
mayor asked me just to introduce Junjo
in a couple of sentences
sure so if you want to accelerate your
career and learn from world-class
operators who build companies like
Amazon like n26 or Google come to junto
and learn from a membership of
chord-based learning in a community of
like-minded peers we're providing a
business education platform for all of
you out there by the way if that sounds
interesting to you we're also hiring a
team across positions so have a look in
the comments and find why junto could be
your next step
thank you Mario so indeed lots of
opportunities try out junto for your
organization maybe even join the team I
will leave a link to johnto in the video
description feel free to check it out
[Music]
now would be interested in your
perspective do you have any tips to add
to this topic of business Angel
Investing let me know in the comments in
other words any value at all that you
took away from this video just throw the
like button for the YouTube algorithm
And subscribe to the channel to stay up
to date on all my content big thanks to
all the members of farm learning as well
my name is weekly videos here on the
channel see you again next week and bye